avait oui non qui faire tuer fait partie
du jury de the voice tous les samedis et
bien jennifer ce soir il ya trois
personnes qui vont venir chanter et tu
nous diras si tu te retourne pas ne te
sens pas obligé de te retourner vraiment
fait comme si tu étais dans the voice
d'accord tu ne te fie qu'à la voir rien
qu'à la voie d'accord alors attention on
va appeler une première personne qui va
chanter qui va nous chanter une chanson
en italien via conomie de paolo conte et
attendez attendez en attendant ton micro
mieux il ya des gens qui travaillent se
tenir ou pas du tout merci je fais tout
allez c'est parti
mais on y va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les bourses nord-américaines tellement
de monde
un match auquel ses qualités la star ac
je trouve qu'elle a une sublime voix oui
tu te serais vraiment retourné dit la
vérité
oui je refuserais la peau d'animaux la
toya jackson oui je sais la jackson sur
son étonnante exxon que tu te serais
asama est-ce que tu serais allé dans
l'équipe de julie fait bien sûr c'est
mon idole passé la seule serait retourné
le faisons c'est jennifer s'il vous
plaît tu peux gagner avec ça va je
trouve qu'elle a une signature vocale
donc mangé une signature vocale alaoui
atur vocal on connaît que sa signature
sur les bulletins
attention jennifer sur retourne à
nouveau on a un deuxième chanteur hockey
deuxième chanteur et après on en aura
pas
[Rires]
je compte les jours jusqu'à ton retour
les années sont passées mais comme je
t'aime on dirait que ça fait que
quelques jours si tu étais là le temps
n'existerait pas on m'a dit du mal sur
toi je suis grand pas je ne veux pas que
l'on sait par de toi j'écoute lavours ta
voix attend les échos de ce qu'on me dit
sur toi ils rendent la route sinueuse un
labyrinthe mais moi je te crois par
l'intermédiaire de cette chanson veux tu
de moi c'est une demande écrite je sais
que je te mérite notre amour est
stabilisé impossible déstabiliser jamais
tiraillée nos coeurs jamais sais pas
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme au premier jour quinze ans
après le coup de foudre dure toujours
on tient le coup on se bat c'est vrai
sur les coups de tonnerre en tire pas
très bons parlant km en année en oeuvre
tous mesure c'est pas du prêt-à-porter
ce que je te propose c'est une robe sur
mesure
j'ai les moyens de toutes les vitrines
que tu regardes que dieu nous garde
esther
bisous
je tends ma main
[Applaudissements]
c'est un honneur au parc même
extrêmement fun ii devient franchement
il est fabuleux c'est beau ce qui l'a
fait connaître
alors attention car et qu'elle soit
parce que là encore jennifer au tournoi
les chéris on va accueillir la troisième
chanteuse une personne qui va chanter
une chanson évoque le chantait on a quoi
belval son museau avant de chanter à
just called to say i love à just called
to say i love you bien sûr de justin
bieber d'accord c'est de stevie wonder
tu connais j'adore tu peux nous la faire
comme ça toi juste un score tout c'est
alain vieux tu sais tout ça
je merci venez faire on va écouter la
personne qui va te chanter à jesse cox
est alors la vue c'est parti on y va à
chase co tout s'est alors vu à chase co
tous et chacun
[Musique]
adjust comme tu sais iloveyou 1 à l'ailé
flore de bodman
alors attendez attendez votre tour mais
ne te retourne pas de mystère que tu ne
s'est pas retourné jennifer tu n'étais
pas retourné sur la voie qu'est une
belle voix mais toi tu aimes les voix
singulière j'ai l'impression qu'on est
résolu
ah oui c'est une très jolie bresse le
jeu l'a reconnu cette voie non je n'ai
pas reconnu cette fois tu ne sais pas du
tout qu'il s'agit non jennifer la
personne ne me connaît et aime la paix
pardon je suis me le connais rem la paix
non jennifer tu penses à qui ça m'amuse
inc m
ce qui est oui c'est alou zink m là je
l'avais oui non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci vanessa mais cela